oh my god it's good batman bad blood i
i'm stunned i am in shock i if you saw
my review of Justice League vs Teen
Titans do you know how little I was
looking for yet you know what just
played the clip I don't want to do
Batman bad blood I really really really
really really don't yeah I was not
looking forward to this at all I was
seriously considering skipping it but
guys it's good it's not just better than
these new than this new 52 based
continuity of films that they've done so
it's not just relative it's good now
coming out of the film I had to actually
think how is it that this was good but
then Justice League vs Teen Titans which
actually was mainly came out after this
but I viewed it first that was so much
better so much worse so how did they fix
the problem the problems came back well
here's the thing when I look at this
film closely they didn't actually fix
the problems they just worked around
them and by that I mean there are three
major problems that I have had with most
of the new 52 based animated films with
Batman ones in particular one Damian
Wayne hate him - Batman's moral compass
has really been out of whack because
they want to have this really
hard-hitting
very harsh violence and yet he's still
espousing you know we have to be
non-lethal and it's not jiving and then
three the fight scenes have been really
dull really boring they're just punch
ups and I'm sick of them this movie
finds ways around all three of them
first of all Damian while he does appear
in it he is not the central focus and
he's taken off the boards for a lot of
this movie he gets incapacitated he gets
restrained he gets restricted he gets
hurt I suppose I'll mention at this
point I'm gonna do my normal rambling
thing I'm gonna actually try and keep
spoilers to a minimum in this case
because you know I actually think it's
worth seeing I don't I don't like
spoiling stuff that I think is good
unless that's the point of the review so
there will be some but I'll try and keep
them to a minimum but
anyway so they managed to minimize
Damien and then as far as Batman is
concerned since the plot of the film is
actually that Batman is missing presumed
dead that means he's not at him for most
of the time and the other characters who
are here don't have established as
strictly non-lethal heck Batwoman uses
guns so the fact that characters are
getting obviously killed in their fights
with the various bat family members is
fine because not only are is Batman not
the person fighting them
he's not even commanding them so they're
kind of doing their own thing so that
fixes that problem and there's enough
variety in the people that we have
fighting that he keeps the fights
interesting because we've got an aerial
aspect because we get batwing who is a
character I actually don't know but he's
you know he's got TechSoup he's flying
around and he's dealing with Killer Moth
and a flying version of Firefly so that
sort of adds a different layer that's
more interesting than the on-the-ground
punch-ups we've been getting but even in
terms of the punch ups there's enough
going on at the same time in almost any
given fight scene because you know
you've got that woman fighting somebody
you've got Nightwing fighting something
you've got back waiting fighting
somebody you've got Damian fighting
somebody and they can cut between those
fights and that keeps it interesting
when it was fights like the Batman
versus Damian fight and Batman versus
Robin it just stays on these two as they
go in and they dodge and they punch and
they get guts so boring this one it can
break it up and move from this one to
this one and this one's going badly but
then it cuts over here and this one's
going better and it just keeps it lively
keeps it from getting boring finally
thank God another nice thing all the
voice acting is got well not all the
voice acting Damian as I said is still
insufferable but the sting is taking off
that not only because he gets minimized
in terms of how it frequently appears
but because he's not around Batman and
he's not around characters who feel
obligated like they have to bond with
him cuz you know in Batman's case it's
his kid he's around characters who are
fine basically telling him to shut up
the villains are much better in this one
of the big ones is the heretic who again
is a character I don't know but I found
him interesting right off the bat in
terms of look and feel and vibe and then
once I found out more about him I found
him really intriguing as as a concept
and the way was being used
I think the villains stuff that happens
in the second half of the movie isn't
quite as good as sort of hits a peak as
we learn more about heretic and then
things good not bad but they get
oversimplified but the action stays good
so it's able to kind of steamroll over
that issue
Batwoman all wow Battlement first of all
her look her design gorgeous I love the
design of this character I love the way
she moves I love the way the hair moves
in that cape is awesome love it and
another great thing and not that this
had necessarily been a problem in new 52
based stories in particular but it is a
frequent issue with superhero stories
particularly dealing with younger
characters which is that whoever they're
trying to hide their secret identity
from this one has basically none of that
there's one toss off side thing with
that Dick Grayson as a girlfriend who
doesn't know but that's basically used
as a joke everyone else everybody knows
who everyone is there's no sidestepping
around like oh I can't let you know who
I am and this important person in my
life doesn't know everybody knows so
that BS is gone and we can just focus on
the stuff that works in the action and
the mystery behind what's going on and
the mystery is pretty good I mean it I
don't think it's a spoiler to say that
Batman is not dead I think you can
figure that out but what actually is
happening who's involved and how it's
panning out is really interesting to
watch unfold bonus props Alfred however
it's really good in this one if I have
any complaints that are beyond nitpicks
there's a certain aspect involved in the
conclusion that gets a bit it's kind of
cheesy and I can't really say more than
that without spoiling it but you know
it's not bad it works but I saw it
coming and it's kind of dull and it's
kind of predictable but it didn't drag
the thing down and it didn't kill the
movie cuz this guy's this is a round
like where assault on Arkham was which
III had honestly come to believe that
the only reason assault on Arkham worked
was because it was not actually part of
this continuity and they weren't stuck
with all the bad decisions this
continuity has made now the thing is I
can't say that this gives me hope for
this continuity anymore because I've
seen Justice League vs Teen Titans
which as I say came out after this and
was terrible and actually what it kind
of tells me is the characters that
they've been focusing on up to this
point are the problem because this was
directed by the same guy who directed
Batman versus Robin which was awful but
once he give him a story where there's
very little Batman and very little Robin
it works and it's really good so I'm
gonna blame these characters and I'm
gonna blame the new 52 version of these
characters but that's me getting in a
down mode on the thing overall but this
one this particular one even if you
don't like the stuff based on the new 52
up to this point give it a watch give it
a chance you may be pleasantly surprised
because I certainly was so that's it for
me on this one guys Batman bad blood
have you seen it what were your thoughts
on it whatever they were drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it don't forget to like subscribe
follow me on Twitter at Council of geeks
check out the council of geeks podcast
on iTunes and stitcher and as for me
I'll be back as soon as I can get my
next fix